[Applause]
uh we're joined now by heidi solsby
health and
social care president for the island of
guernsey good afternoon to thank you for
your time
uh today so this is all about the as you
call it the baileywick
bubble what's that yeah absolutely um
it's such a fantastic day for bayer rick
of guernsey
as you say 51 days without any positive
cases
88 days of lockdown but today all
restrictions have gone within the island
so
everything is is open and it's a
wonderful day the sun is shining
and really it's great no restrictions at
all so
people can uh mill around bars that
everybody can go to the bar and they can
um they can go to restaurants without
having to worry about social distancing
so
cinemas everything they're all open
before but not
before we had lockdown uh how have you
managed to achieve that i guess um
guernsey's got a population about some
67 000
the uk has 67 million so perhaps easier
in a way
well we're different i mean clearly but
um one of the things we did we locked
down early
when we were we were concerned about
what was happening around us
um and we also brought in very early
testing tracking
and tracing and that was key to being
able to control the infection
but overall really this is all down to
the community
the response we've had has just been
overwhelming i mean
people as in the uk will have made
sacrifices
of self-isolation people not being able
to
see loved ones who who may be dying in
care homes or
or attend funerals so a lot of people
have suffered over this time and
in terms of jobs and really from a
financial point of view as well
but everybody is the whole community has
come together
and really it's been quite humbling
because we never
even attempted to say right we would
look at eliminating the virus
and so it's beyond our wildest
expectations that would be
51 days and we haven't seen a single
positive case
so the key you would say is this testing
and contact
uh tracing which obviously has been
delayed in england for a while and
things just recently
uh getting underway um what's
your reaction to what's happening in
england with that
you've obviously gone and got on with it
quite quickly
yeah well as you say the uk is different
from guernsey and we are
we do things that can do things
differently i think we have been very
lucky with the
the advice and support we've had from
our director of public health
and and the teamwork that we've had and
we've taken
we've looked at the evidence and and
that has guided us
in our decision making i think early on
we were concerned with we we were then
reliant on the uk
for testing and and the times were
between getting
um making it having the tests and
getting results were very slow and
that was one of the reasons why we were
concerned and went into lockdown so
since then we we got our own um trucking
uh testing system on ireland and that's
really um
really held us in good stead because it
meant that we could we could test
immediately and then
our contact racing teams a fantastic
bunch of people and work
that has 24 hours a day seven days a
week
in some instances really getting that
contact tracing happening
and that has really meant that we've
been able to control the
the infection as much as possible as
quickly as possible and
that that has contributed to everything
the first case
in guernsey was confirmed wasn't it the
9th of march so what's
life been like on the island in the past
few weeks and months
well it's people i mean people have just
abided by what
what's been brilliant is that people
have listened to us
and trusted us and what we said and
we've been we've been very open as well
if things haven't worked
we've said they haven't worked we've
been honest and open we've told them
how things are going and what we've what
we're asking them to do
and really to a man woman child that
they've
they've supported us and it's been it's
been absolutely fantastic we've had
the guernsey flag outside people's homes
because at this point
in may we have our liberation day which
is the uh
the day when we celebrate freedom after
german occupation
at the end of the second world war and
we couldn't properly celebrate that but
people
kept their flags out in front of their
houses it meant
meant so much we've had collapse of
carers and people going to the hospital
and clapping for for our health and care
workers
it really it's been epitomised in the
phrase guernsey together
people have rallied around it and it's
it's been absolutely fantastic for
the community and and today the sun is
like the sun is shining and it it just
couldn't be better really